tis the season to buy gifts and Rising
prices are on many Shoppers Minds
inflation may be slowing in the United
States but prices are still way up over
last year and holiday sales are lagging
system like prize hikes this year things
are a lot more expensive than they they
typically are it feels like it's a
holiday so I don't want to shortchange
anyone but you know things are more
expensive noticeably in an effort to
reduce and
the FED has been raising interest rates
from near zero in March to just under
four and a half percent by Year's End
and Jerome Powell made clear recently he
wasn't ready to stop the increases just
yet I don't think anyone knows
uh whether we're going to have a
recession or not and if we do whether
it's going to be a deep one or not it's
just it's not knowable still it's not
all bad news wages for the lowest
earners have gone up considerably and
the labor market remains strong
you're somebody who's stocking that milk
in the grocery store you're noticing
your wages have risen more in the past
three years than in the past 20 years
and your chance of getting a job or
quitting your job if you don't like it
and getting a better one are better than
they've been in 20 or 25 years of course
it's not just holiday presents that have
gotten more expensive it's things like
rent and mortgage rates and services
like haircuts so some economists are
worried that raising interest rates may
do more harm than good
last week the bank of England and the
European Central Bank followed the FED
raising rates by half a percentage point
to three and a half percent and two and
a half percent
but higher interest rates could
discourage businesses from making new
Investments it's already making it
harder for poor countries also dealing
with inflation to pay back loans the U.N
says 54 countries are at risk of
defaulting most of the world's poorest
countries find themselves on what one
could call depth row
staring down the abyss of insolvency and
default
this year alone the adapt service
payments skyrocketed 35 percent the
largest increase in decades
and with credit card debt Rising this
holiday season many families say Santa
will have to tighten his belt we went in
with like expectations like Hey we're
going to get this and get this and then
we went in and the prices have gone up
we're like yeah well not right now we'll
just hold off they too will feel the
pinch of higher interest rates in the
new year
Kristen salumi Al Jazeera New York